en este vídeo quiero platicar acerca de
una de las fuerzas más misteriosas del
universo y para eso voy a empezar
hablando acerca de la carga eléctrica le
voy a poner aquí carga eléctrica
y eléctrica sale esto de la carga
eléctrica tiene mucho que ver con eso de
cargar la batería de tu computadora
bueno la carga eléctrica es una
propiedad que viene en dos tipos
distintos un objeto puede tener carga
positiva en cuyo caso se aleja de otros
objetos que también tienen carga
positiva o bien un objeto puede tener
carga negativa y ahora estos dos objetos
como tienen carga distinta entonces se
atraen vale se atraen y esto del nombre
de carga positiva o carga negativa pues
es una convención pero es un poco
arbitraria sea bien podríamos haber
llamado a esta la carga verde y a esta
la carga naranja y todo seguiría
funcionando igual lo importante es que
hay dos tipos de carga dos tipos de
carga que cargas e iguales se alejan de
cargas distintas se atraen
vamos a seguir llamándole positiva y
negativa bueno entonces la carga
eléctrica es una propiedad le voy a
poner aquí que es una propiedad
y de hecho esta propiedad viene desde
las partículas propiedad las partículas
pueden tener carga positiva o carga
negativa y adjuntar todas las partículas
eso le da al objeto la propiedad de
tener cierta carga pero en realidad
cuando digo que es una propiedad estoy
diciendo que fundamentalmente no sé que
es en realidad nadie fundamentalmente
sabe que es la carga eléctrica bueno en
realidad bueno o sea fundamentalmente se
conocen pocas cosas pero pero bueno o
sea no importa lo importante es que es
una propiedad y que es más o menos una
propiedad como como la masa o como el
peso o como el volumen
estas son propiedades un poco más
tangibles verdad la cosa con la carga es
que es una propiedad un poco más
abstracta de hecho no se tuvimos que
empezar a jugar con con piedras de ámbar
y nos tuvieron que empezar a caer rayos
para más o menos agarrarle la onda a
esto de la carga eléctrica bueno
entonces la carga eléctrica es una
propiedad que viene en dos tipos
distintos los nombres son más o menos
arbitrarios se los pusimos
en algún momento y ya son positivo y
negativo pero ya que la carga es una
propiedad sería bueno poder medirla de
alguna forma
bueno pues las unidades para medir la
carga las unidades para medir la carga
son los con long con long vale los colom
y esto colombia viene de del nombre de
un científico de los años más o menos
1700 que jugaba con cargas y con
electricidad puede leer un poco más
acerca de él en la wikipedia o bien
buscarlo en google pero bueno aunque ya
tengamos un nombre para la unidad de la
carga sería bueno agarrar un poco de
intuición de cuánto es un culo o en
términos de que está dado y para eso
vamos a platicar acerca de átomos vale
los átomos tienen un núcleo en donde hay
partículas elementales un tipo de
partículas elementales que hay en el
núcleo son los neutrones que ahorita no
nos van a interesar mucho pero otros que
sí nos interesan son los protones los
protones
vale y esos protones tienen carga
positiva bueno vamos a decir que la
carga de un protón es positiva otra vez
es una convención entonces la carga de
los protones es positiva bueno los
átomos además de tener estas cosas en el
núcleo también tienen otras partículas
que se llaman electrones que están
girando alrededor están girando por acá
y por acá y resulta que esos tienen
carga negativa tienen carga negativa los
electrones son mucho más chiquitos y en
realidad hay muchos problemas cuando uno
habla de electrones porque no sabemos si
son reales o no o sea si causan ciertos
fenómenos pero es como muy difícil decir
si sí o sea si son más como un objeto o
un concepto si son masa o si son energía
entonces son más o menos complicados y
más o menos se piensa en ellos a
conveniencia favorita lo que nos
interesa es que tienen carga negativa
son bastante más chiquitos que los
neutrones y que los protones vale
una cosa súper sorprendente es que los
protones y los electrones tienen
exactamente la misma carga mantienen
exactamente la misma carga en magnitud
solo que uno tiene carga positiva y el
otro tiene carga negativa y bueno ya que
así son las cosas pues sería bueno que
nuestra unidad fundamental de carga
tuviera que ver con protones y con
electrones y bueno si resulta que la
unidad fundamental de carga se conoce
como que se conoce como e y justamente
es la carga de un protón carga d
un protón
brotóns por lo que platicamos entonces
menos
sería la carga de un electrón voy a
poner aquí carga d
un electrón el electrón y entendiendo
estas cosas ya podemos entender un
poquito más qué es un culo porque un
culo me está dado en términos de estas
unidades fundamentales y un culo de
hecho es igual a bueno un colon se
define como
como la carga que tenemos en 6.24
por 10 a la 18 protones o sea un colon
de 6.24 por 10 a las 18 cargas o bien
unidades fundamentales vale ahora es
útil poner las cosas al revés o sea
poner la unidad fundamental en términos
de colomos entonces haciendo bueno
haciendo la división queda que que una
unidad fundamental o bien la carga de un
protón es igual a 1.6
1.6 por 10 a la menos 19 culos muy bien
ahora estos números pueden parecer un
poco arbitrarios o sea a lo mejor te
preguntas por qué pondríamos 6.24 por 10
a la 18
y unidades fundamentales aquí y bueno
después cuando platicamos un poquito de
electricidad vamos a agarrarle un poco
más de intuición por el momento nada más
imagínate qué bueno son estos números de
acá imagínate qué estado de alguna forma
y bueno si te preguntas y si te los
tienes que memorizar o no pues o sea
sería bueno pero en la mayoría de los
problemas que te dan estas constantes o
al menos una de estas y entonces puedes
encontrar la otra vale
entonces hasta ahorita tenemos que la
carga eléctrica es una propiedad que
viene en dos tipos distintos objetos con
la misma carga se alejan objetos con
cargas distintas se atraen y ya sabemos
más o menos cómo medir esta propiedad ya
platicamos acerca de de protones y de
electrones y entonces el culo me está
dado en términos de cargas de protones
vale con esta fórmula de aquí después
para medir la carga de un objeto pues lo
que se hace es ver cuántos protones y
cuántos electrones tiene osea no se
cuentan pero básicamente es lo que acaba
pasando en el fondo vale si el objeto
tiene más protones electrones entonces
tiene carga positiva si tiene
electrones que protones entonces tiene
carga negativa muy bien ahora ya que
entendimos estas ideas sería bueno
entender por qué estos objetos se alejan
y esos se acercan entonces déjame poner
otra vez dos cargas positivas
que se están alejando entre sí y vamos a
poner una carga positiva y una negativa
una carga positiva y una carga y una
carga negativa hasta entonces porque
porque se alejarían o acercarían estas
dos cargas entre sí bueno si tenemos un
objeto en reposo y se empieza a mover
por alguna razón por definición por mera
definición eso quiere decir que hay una
cierta aceleración y para que haya una
aceleración entonces pues debe de debe
de suceder que la carga por alguna razón
esté generando cierta fuerza y si no
tenemos fuerza no tenemos aceleración y
si resulta que en efecto así es la carga
genera cierta fuerza y esa fuerza está
dada por la siguiente ecuación que se
conoce como la ley de colom este mismo
color
y bueno la ley de coulomb lo que nos
dice es que esa fuerza con la cual las
partículas se alejan o bien se atraen
está dada por una cierta constante
eléctrica ahorita platicamos de ella
multiplicada por las cargas y dividido
entre la distancia de las cargas la
distancia entre las cargas al cuadrado
observa esta fórmula se parece muchísimo
a la ley de gravitación vamos a ponerle
aquí que es para la fuerza eléctrica y
aquí voy a poner la la de la fuerza
gravitacional la fórmula para la fuerza
gravitacional era igual a la constante
gravitacional a una cierta constante
gravitacional multiplicada por por la
masa de los objetos y dividido entre la
distancia de los objetos al cuadrado que
voy a poner el cuadrado más abajo
observa estas dos fórmulas se parecen
muchísimo y lo que nos dice es que estas
dos fuerzas pues deberían de parecerse
muchísimo entre sí y la verdad si se
parecen bastante de hecho bueno aquí
viene como que la parte mágica de
cualquiera de estas dos y bueno no se
usa pensamos tanto en en la fuerza
gravitacional al poner por ahí un objeto
y otro objeto por acá no importa qué tan
lejos esté como que esta fórmula nos
dice que esos objetos saben que están
ahí
este objeto sabe que este está y este
sabe que este está y entonces se empieza
a ver una cierta fuerza que los atrae
eso está muy mágico como que se
comunican entre sí de alguna forma de
modo similar si ponemos cargas entonces
por alguna razón esas cargas sin que
nadie se los diga saben que se tienen
que alejar o acercar eso está padrísimo
me parece maravilloso y me parece
bastante misterioso no sé a ti bueno si
lo piensas tantito si es bastante
misterioso y bueno después cuando bueno
si en algún momento hablamos de
relatividad resulta que esta ecuación es
más o menos lo que le da la forma al
universo
el fenómeno detrás de esta ecuación hace
que el universo tenga la forma que tiene
y bueno también pasa lo mismo con esta
ecuación de acá o sea como que esta
ecuación nos puede ayudar a entender un
poquito qué sucede con el universo pero
bueno vamos vamos a regresar un poco a
esta fórmula y vamos a ver qué nos dice
básicamente nos dice que la fuerza
eléctrica es directamente proporcional
al producto de las cargas y es
inversamente proporcional a la distancia
de las cargas al cuadrado vale entonces
es lo que nos dice esta fórmula en él
y ahora sí vamos a platicar tantito de
esta constante acá esta constante acá es
igual
9 por 10 a la 9 bueno en realidad este 9
es una aproximación sería muy
impresionante que fuera un 9 es nueva
por 10 a la 9 y las unidades que
tendrían que ser pues bueno aquí
queremos newtons verdad porque es una
fuerza newtons y aquí tenemos que poner
algo que se cancele con estas unidades
de acá aquí es colon cuadrado entre
metro cuadrado entonces tendría que ser
metro cuadrado entre colon cuadrado para
que al final nos quede newtons bueno ok
entonces esta de aquí es la constante y
ya con esto tenemos como poder calcular
la fuerza vamos a hacer un problema para
que queden un poco más claras las ideas
y bueno aunque platiqué mucho de los
fenómenos que causan esto y ya
reflexionamos un poco de la profundidad
resulta que los problemas son son muy
sencillos
por ejemplo este problema dice tenemos
una carga positiva de 5 por 10 a la
menos 3 kilos y tenemos una carga
negativa negativa de menos porque es
negativa 10 por 10 a la menos dos kilos
paradas a una distancia de 0.5 metros
voy a ponerle así
esto de aquí es 0.5 metros entonces la
pregunta dice determina la fuerza con la
cual estas partículas están siendo
atraídas atraídas porque son distintas
verdad
bueno pues cómo le hacemos simplemente
utilizamos la ley de colom vamos a poner
todos los datos que nos dan nos dicen la
fuerza eléctrica
que atrae a las partículas es igual a la
constante que es 9 por 10 a la 9 x la
primera carga 5 por 10 a la menos 3 x la
segunda carga menos 10 por 10 a la menos
2 y esto dividido dividido entre la
distancia de las cargas al cuadrado o
sea entre un medio al cuadrado muy bien
vamos a ver cuánto nos da esto de aquí
es igual a 9 por 5 es 45 por menos 10 es
menos 450
por 10 a la 93 de 6 234 por dieta la
cuatro y eso dividido entre un cuarto y
un cuarto esto de aquí cuánto nos da
pues este cuarto está en el denominador
este en cuartos en el denominador el 4
puede pasar multiplicando nos quedaría
menos 4 por 450 mil 800 menos 1.800 por
10 a la 4 y vamos a simplificar lo tanto
más para ponerlo en notación científica
es menos 1.8 recorrimos 123 por 10 a la
4 13 7 por 10 a las 7 newtons muy bien
observa esta carga tiene una magnitud
grandísima es del orden de 10 a las 7
newtons y eso tiene que ver con que las
cargas que puse aquí son son bastante
grandes y en realidad las partículas no
están tan alejadas entre sí y este menos
este menos lo que nos dice es justamente
que las partículas se están acercando
vale entonces el signo del signo de aquí
te va a decir si las partículas
alejando o si se están atrayendo si no
te acuerdas cuál es cuál es muy fácil
pensarlo en términos de lo que ya
platicamos en este vídeo si el signo es
menos las cargas serán distintas y
entonces se atraen y si aquí es más es
porque las cargas eran igual y entonces
se repelen bueno creo que ya me pasé
bastante de mi tiempo usual nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo